Speaker 1: Which brings us to the other side,
the other camp and Republicans who in an effort
to own the Libs.
Which seems to be their only function.
They are pushing back against every measure
imaginable.
To beat back the virus, whether that be mask
mandates, whether that be vaccines, whether
that be social distancing, whether that be
shut downs, whatever effect they had on the
economy at every step.
They push back.
Enter Josh Feuerstein, another one of these
evangelical nutter butters who screams and
yells and freaks out on stage to their audience,
their congregation.
Listen, again, get a little personal, since
most people don't know who I am, I grew up
a conservative Republican.
I was indoctrinated in an evangelical congregation
for most of my time for all of my childhood.
I revered characters like Josh Feuerstein,
like Greg Locke, who David talked about a
few days ago.
These are dangerous charlatans.
Watch this clip from Josh Feuerstein, then
we're going to talk about it.
Listen to me here.
I understand.
Speaker 2: Let me speak now to the cameras
around the world, to every pastor that's watching
this broadcast, to every Christian that has
power in your home.
I realize that for this last year that maybe
you've been fed fear and fear and fear.
But the Bible says that God has not given
us the spirit of fear, but a power of love
and a sound mind.
You want a sound, but you don't have to wear
the mask.
You've got Jesus.
Speaker 1: You don't need the vaccine.
You got Jesus.
So I guess we're to believe that Josh Feuerstein,
who much like me, could could use a few sit
ups in his life.
That he's not vaccinated for anything, apparently
he doesn't have the the measles, mumps, rubella
vaccine, he's probably not been vaccinated
for polio, right.
It's only this vaccine that's the problem
because it's the culture war du jour for conservatives
and grifter's just like him.
Who ostensibly has a charge to protect his
flock.
He is doing a disservice not just to the people
in the audience who look up to him and admire
him, he is doing a disservice to the country
at large as he appears on American real America's
voice.
Like they're part of real America and those
of us who disagree are not in real America.
This is all part and parcel pattern and practice
with what is taking place right now.
In the headlines Ferrin talked about over
the last couple of days, a couple of guys,
Dick Farrell, the Newsmax and Florida radio
host, who who said not to get vaccinated,
who called covid a hoax, who's now dead.
From covid.
H. Scott Apley, a Republican.
The leader in the Republican Party in Texas.
Advertised a mask burning party and said,
boy, I wish I could live where you guys are,
I'd love to be a part of that.
He died on Wednesday.
In an effort to own the labs to prove their
points.
They're acting.
As they always do about most issues of import,
and that is until it passes beyond their nose,
like a like a conservative who is all against
gay rights until they have a gay kid, the
same thing is happening because the two gentlemen
that I just talked about that have been talked
about more in length by farand the last few
days.
They're their families are admonishing everyone,
please get the vaccine, covid is real, covid
is a killer.
And the problem that we face right now is
not just from local city councilmen in Texas
or Newsmax radio hosts, it's with prominent
governors and the Republican Party like Rhonda
Santurce right now.
Who just today announced he's threatening
to cut the pay, suspend the pay of of school
districts, of teachers, educators, superintendents
if they enforce a mask mandate protecting
children.
This headline from CBS for Miami Governor
Ronda Santurce Office State Education Board
could withhold salaries of superintendents,
school board members who implement Marzook
mandates.
Here's the word from Rhonda Santurce, someone
who is not protecting children.
As we see covid rates rise among children,
hospitalization rise among children.
Ron DeSantis is making it a policy objective
to not protect the least among us, the most
vulnerable among us.
His statement with respect to enforcing any
financial consequences for noncompliance of
state law regarding these rules and ultimately
the rights of parents to make decisions about
their children's education and health care
decisions.
It would be the goal of the State Board of
Education to narrowly tailor any financial
consequences to the offense committed.
For example, the State Board of Education
could move to withhold the salary of this
district superintendent or school board members
as a narrowly tailored means to address the
decision makers who led to the violation of
the law, who led to the violation of the law,
but also led to the protection of children.
He continues, education funding is intended
to benefit students first and foremost.
Rhonda Santurce said it with his own mouth
here by his own pin or someone in his office,
that education funds intended to benefit students
first and foremost.
And that doesn't just mean benefiting them
and their actual education, but keeping them
safe in the place where they are educated.
Just recently on Meet the Press with Chuck
Todd, the the president of the second largest
teachers union, decided they're going to reverse
course and they're going to support a covid
vaccine mandate because of that very thing,
protecting children.
Randi Weingarten, president of the American
Federation of Teachers, all with Meet the
Press.
Watch this.
Speaker 3: But I do think that the circumstances
have changed and that vaccination is a community
responsibility.
And it weighs really heavily on me that kids
under 12 can't get vaccinated.
And so that's so, you know, that's I very
rarely, you know, separate my personal views
from, you know, where I am as a leader of
the union.
But I have really watched, particularly in
Florida and Missouri.
I was in St. Louis yesterday.
I was in Florida on Saturday.
And you just see this and and we have to counter
look, you said it earlier.
We have to counter the misinformation.
We have to do with this is a public health
crisis and the politics are infecting it.
But I felt the need, as you know, to bring
people together and to stand up and say this
as a matter of personal conscience, pointedly
stated.
Speaker 1: Circumstances have changed and
this is about it weighs really heavily on
me that kids under 12 can't get vaccinated.
It should weigh heavily on every single person
in America, educator or not pastor or not
politician or not.
Stupid commentator or not?
People are dying, our neighbors are dying.
In our lifetime, unless you're one hundred
years old, we've not seen something rip through.
Our society like this.
Which team are you going to be on, the team
that cares?
Or the team that colludes against
the team that cares.